voici donc cinq conseils pour survivre
l'inflation alimentaire avec nous ce
soir vicky payeur qui est créatrice du
blog vivre avec moins et autres s
également du livre vivre avec moins pour
faire la place à l'essentiel bonsoir un
vampire
allons-y avec des conseils très simple
pour les gens conseil numéro un vous
dites qu'il faut faire des listes et
vérifier les soldes et les liquidations
oui exactement la première chose que je
fais toutes les semaines je regarde les
circulaires puis on le répète souvent
mais c'est vraiment l'astuce qui est
essentiel pour réduire sa facture
d'épicerie donc je fais ma liste
d'épicerie mais attention après ça c'est
là que je fais comme le chemin inverse
plutôt que de regarder un livre de
recettes et d'acheter les ingrédients
que j'ai besoin pour créer mon menu de
la semaine je fais plutôt le chemin
inverse donc je regarde les ingrédients
que j'ai sous la main les ingrédients
qui sont en promotion et après je vais
aller chercher une recette donc ça me
permet vraiment de réduire la facture
des fichiers mais également je reste à
l'affût des liquidations et des
réductions à l'épicerie pour trouver les
meilleures promotions excellent premier
conseil deuxième conseil conseil numéro
2 pour survivre l'inflation achetés en
grandes quantités et les gros format
oui exactement donc dans les magasins
entrepôt ainsi on peut trouver des
aliments en grande quantité et souvent
servi ou en charge de les acheter en
petit sachet à l'épicerie donc ma
meilleure astuce et de regarder le prix
aux 100 g ch et sur les étiquettes de
pied bien souvent et là on va pouvoir
savoir si on fait de réelles économies
donc moi par exemple minois je les
achète par kilo et ça me revient
vraiment moins cher plutôt que si je les
ai acheté un petit sachet à l'épicerie
mais par contre pour faire attention
parce que si mal lorsqu'on achète en
grande quantité ça peut nous influencer
à surconsommer et à manger davantage
donc que tout simplement de garder ça en
tête pour gérer nos stocks
vont gérer nos stocks et nos inventaires
c'est important et notre garde-manger
conseil numéro 3 acheter des fruits
congelés
exactement donc on s'est surtout à
l'hiver ici au québec les prix des
fruits prix est assez élevé donc moi on
a cessé d'aller voir dans le ayons
surgelés voir c'est quoi les promotions
de la semaine donc pas plus tard que la
semaine passée j'ai acheté un sac de
petits fruits congelés à seulement 3
dollars 99 en promotion pour 600 grammes
alors que d'acheter une petite barquette
de framboises dans le rayon prêt aurait
coûté le mintier donc le genre n'est
vraiment plus pour mon argent et je peux
les mettre dans des smoothies et dans
mon griots du matin donc il ya vraiment
mille et une des utilisations qu'on peut
faire avec ça
conseil numéro cup vous dit de suivre de
près les prix de la viande
expliquez nous donc dans une circulaire
en est les viandes en promotion pendant
la semaine vont être affichés donc c'est
de vérifier le prix à la livre donc de
regarder au fil du temps à force de
regarder circulaire on veut savoir c'est
quoi les meilleures promotions c'est
quand le meilleur qui sur la viande et
pas plus tard qu'il ya deux semaines un
des cuisses de plus été aussi basse que
0,99 dollar l'année ou encore cette
semaine les pilons de poulet 1 288 cas
les endroits 99 l'aller donc il ya
encore moyen de trouver de la viande à
petit prix et on sait le boeuf c'est
comme une victime données de l'inflation
donc si jamais c'est pas une promotion
une semaine précise c'est tout
simplement d'attendre peut-être la
semaine suivante et à ce moment là elle
voit est en réduction et à ce moment là
on prend la met sur notre menu de la
semaine dernier conseille d'utiliser des
outils et des applications
expliquez-nous des applications des
applications web
mais exactement donc maintenant les
chaînes d'alimentation ont leurs propres
applications de liquidation on pense à
vous dire oh on pense à flash sud donc
c'est des applications qui proposent des
aliments qui approche la date de
péremption mais qui sont encore super
bon pour la consommation
donc on peut économiser 30 50 % sur la
viande mais aussi pour les produits
frais ça peut être très intéressant donc
parfois je vois souvent des très grandes
boîtes de fruits et de légumes mélangés
pour aussi peu que cinq dollars il
suffit de les consommer dans les deux
trois jours suivants ou encore de les
placer au congélateur pour avoir déposé
fait outrées toute la semaine c'est des
bons conseils l'équipe ailleurs merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit